marc andré clément vient d'acheter la
salle de bingo de saint-eustache qui
appartenait à ses parents même si la
tendance à long terme est négative
je veux une fois dans ma carrière voire
une coque qui augmente depuis 12 ans
carrière ma courbe et descend dans les
salles ferment c'est supposé dire
quelque chose il faut une volonté
politique de changer ça la cour dans
monte
il y avait 50 de salles de bingo
commercial au québec en 2008 il n'en
restait plus que 30 et une au début 2000
20 et 24 seulement sont encore en
activité généralement l'ensemble des
salles au québec depuis au moins dix ans
dont l'avant des activités connexes
certains renvoient des restaurants
certainement avant des bars annexe au
bingo même s'ils peuvent pas reprendre
de consommation dans la salle ils vont
avoir un bar certains sont chanceux ont
des machines de loterie vidéo
environ 60% des gains nets des salles de
bingo vont aux gestionnaires de salles
pour payer ses dépenses
les 40% restants sont versés à des
organismes communautaires locaux un peu
plus de 11 millions de dollars par année
et est versée à 400 obnl avant la
pandémie mais avec la fermeture
définitive de certaines salles seulement
255 reçoivent encore des dons la salle
de saint-eustache romain normalement un
million par année à une quinzaine
d'organismes communautaires
on a environ 50 à 60 milles par année
donc tout dépend des années et pour nous
ça représente environ 10% d'un autre
budget global
énormément de souper spaghetti qu'il
faudrait qu'on fasse pour arriver à 50
milles par année et ça permet aussi nous
concentrer plus sur notre mission notre
base stud aide à la population
si cette mission sociale qui motive marc
andré clément j'ai une phase ii dans ma
vie dans ma jeunesse
puis les usb elles m'ont aidé comme
d'autres gestionnaires ils aimeraient
rajeunir la clientèle dans certaines
provinces ont séparé la salle en deux
pour créer une ambiance lounge avec a
permis d'alcool d'un côté qui des
sessions plus rapide avec des fruits
combinée avec un dj une plus grande
flexibilité avec des jeux électroniques
dits spéciaux quand il ya beaucoup de
monde et la possibilité de jouer
quelques parties seulement faciliterait
aussi l'accueil de nouveaux clients
les gens sont obligés de s'asseoir ici
pendant moyens une période de trois
heures de temps en 1re s au pouvoir
faire des sessions d'une heure puis les
gens puissent acheter des cartes juste
pour le nombre de sessions qui veulent
jouer
malheureusement la réglementation est
pas adapté à ce type de modèle là des
discussions sont en cours avec la régie
des alcools des courses et des jeux pour
alléger certaines règles tous les
provinces qui ont débuté un programme de
modernisation ont eu des résultats on
est non seulement une augmentation de
recettes mais profits distribuée aux
organismes mais aussi plus d'organismes
sont bénéficiaires de ces retombées là
je veux juste avoir une meilleure offre
pour métier si mes clients vont être
heureux la salle va bien aller ce la
salle va bien les joueuses bl vont bien
qui l'avenir de la famille sécurisé pour
transmettre l'entreprise familiale à ces
pays il faudra d'abord assurer la relève
de sa clientèle ici marie claude morin
radio-canada saint-eustache
[Musique]